in southern Iraq this is the only School
for students with impaired
eyesight despite his blindness esmat
Abdul Hafiz has obtained a bachelor's
degree he has returned to the elementary
school he attended 25 years ago he says
he wants to help students make a
difference in their
lives I returned to pay back the favor
and teach these kids what I learned
through the years I a spiritual
connection with this place the lack of
books printed and bra language is a
major
challenge the bra language system is new
for those who are being educated here
reading and writing using their
fingertips helps them build confidence
and
Independence the most difficult part is
turning school books into Braille
characters we have only a couple of
special printers PR in a single textbook
takes about 15 days also switching
printing from Arabic to English is a big
deal so we do the English version
manually even though they're missing out
on many activities these students are as
Ken to learn and get their grades as
cited students and some of them find
they can learn faster by just
listening they rely on senses other than
their vision and group together for
Mutual
support but they get little backing from
outside and conditions are
tough we are short of staff and
classrooms while the number of students
is increasing our teachers need special
training unfortunately this category of
society is marginalized in Iraq in order
for us to maintain this school the
government should take care of it es
says his physical disability hasn't
dimmed his bright Spirit he has
reproduced more than 2,000 books since
2019 and these students now hope to
produce text using Braille calibrated
computers another step forward in their
vision of a brighter
future mm ABD Al jaaz Basra Southern
Iraq make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz
out